he's got 14 that being will port and
Torrey Craig and yogic McGee take his
game to another level look at this
bounce pass to McGee they can roll with
heart come on that's pre-play couple
guards working out if it was traded for
miles bridges he's had a great start his
rookie year - all on the move to get it
to caldwell-pope
and he scoops it in to about Rondo and
his assist when just picked up another
one on the pass to Casey being the
left-hand layup nice job here it was
definitely finishing around the rim good
hands by Rajan dos nice visions
[Applause]
Rondo play where he's the flex it runs
the floor then throws up the lotta Kuzma
who finishes off to play that's that's
exciting basketball when you get that
kind of pace and especially those kind
of results well you look at the numbers
he certainly had a transition flight by
the lake and he certainly had a very
good looking yes T by having the best
player on the court play a little bit
deeper
I feel amend that to say unless your
name is Stauskas
thanks passing Gaines lays it in off the
assist the smartest players in the
league beautiful left hand passed that
was an all time defensive possession by
JaVale McGee Rondo Stephenson another
two points 24 games yet they still 165
[Music]
Aling up to the game and stopped up to
the rosin throw it down to Vail McGee I
can't say enough about the rim run
defensively but the Lakers trying to
build the gate fortunate very gotta
start making buckets bounce glide all
the bounce timeout really long drought
where they haven't been able to generate
blood from the offensive in they still
only see themself down by four points
under some duress Stephenson at the
other end
let's lays it in on another great outlet
Rondo at a nice outlet pass and
Stephenson able to just catch it if you
know the free-for-all fifteen points off
the turnovers for Minnesota Rondo good
tip the heart finishes with the two
hands another look at that play with
Rondo maybe she finds Josh Hart
nice dive nice little bounce Lakers on
offense they're good the third highest
scoring team this time LeBron won't make
a mistake and a good feed underneath to
right there to 12 all run
[Music]
that's sue sue what the throwdown
yeah nice and read by Ron just slowing
it down and built with the bots little
bit too early that you don't confront
keep their tempo born that was a prop
against Dallas they know a challenge
sends up late the game at Hall for when
use if this applies especially when you
go small if you're going to switch and
end up with little guarding a big guy
that you can rely on just got to plays
better
McGee throws that I put in double
figures in the first half for JaVale
McGee drive to pooper scoopers had it
feel each leg guest 2% trouble then the
Lakers are going down emphatic Lee Burt
look like Newark is who's going to try
to go behind the back and then McKee
with a good play three on one Lakers
Stephenson lays it in
holiday pizza cutting Dave is broken up
by James Rondo flops Ingram throws it
down
minutes Rajon Rondo short clock oh good
now 270 scores again zübeyde shot but
nice job of picking it's rolling to the
painted area and get the past and round
up the overreact I want to take a
malware of his Chandler McGee who makes
a mistake you could just live with Ron
dollars Oh hawks they connect once again
we can overlook also his competitive
spirit back shot I know he's back his
right hand is feeling good and therefore
his teammates are feeling good because
they get the touch toe with the broken
finger
oh wow I thought he got away with an
offensive foul guy he'll shoot la those
here in LA Cylons were in my face just
the beautiful blue delivery there by
Rondo an equally impressive finish Raja
Valley and I think this second group if
they can operate where they come in
transition to trying to find that right
guy to trying to get a good half court
set food let's see to me that's the
bigger issue
Roger a pass to get it to serenity 15
turnovers they had 25 points off there
so it's just this handle tick take care
of that and again they got it
citizens ball walking at his back
pediment Ingram's see in the play two
three steps and hits that pass Rondo
this is a very difficult pass for make
that bounce pass and drop it off good
luck everybody please double agents with
the basketball
start stop baseline cut it
[Music]
that saved and he throws it down with
two hands I don't know how Rondo found
Ingram Ingram and Brandon with a nice
boy
ends up with the dunk and the Clippers
take time other terrific pass by Kevin
Durant five assists for Durant Rondo
Sioux box foul one Rondo with a terrific
pass for his fifth assist from Rondo for
quite a while now the ability to force
the defense to make a decision at that
time he drove and he kicked it to the
wide open green and then you went over
this before relocated he was open Rondo
nice speed and Ingram the fish Brandon
Ingram having a whale of a game see how
quick they get him the basketball and
the decisions he makes there's only one
place to put that basketball and Rondo
does it
[Applause]
born ready welcome back to Indy this
time down the floor two minutes in to
the first waterlogged oh good because
modes then cycle the store enough of a
little head fake Turner left his feet
when he left his feet he was all over
your guard to rule is attacking on the
Celtic side but you can't find anyone
that you can't score boxing oh what a
pass slot go on the bounce it's
entertaining but it's it's it's not sort
about the standard you wish
how truism has been a bit of a headache
against you guys what do you have to do
to contain him here in the fourth front
court with the yoyo dribbled out
terminates bouncing - coos both boy -
spin turn and score off the window Vijay
with 220 left goes
underneath Kuzma story Lakers down by
for their fourth class the James
nicely done by one game that's just a
post up got two more Diallo five to five
a dozen points in the game
hey CP gets behind the defense to lay it
in each team with over 30 points in the
premiere 3:25 to play is to get another
look at the pass them and teams that are
currently in the playoffs
now their schedules difficult they're
gonna have to play great basketball
- Kitty after the Anthony Davis
controversy has played their best
basketball when he's been on the bench
or not one loose ball with the shot
clock at two it ends up in the hands of
Ingram and he slams it and that tape
comes off the finger I think it's a
telltale sign Rondo out to James he'll
try another three
[Applause]
[Music]
tried to get it around the e because not
Rondo's finds caldwell-pope in a corner
on a three
this is the Kingston friend and Reggie
Bullock taken away defense to offense
three-on-one Roger
finish up LeBron the timeout is wanted
board the other night got it well ready
to start with Magette
got every guarding LeBron James and
agenda the last game that is 2 for 2 so
far the night look at this slam a great
job of running the court by cooze will
be another look at that hook pass by
Rondo to the streaky Kuzma that's way
you run a fast-break run for a dudes
don't always run for behind a lot get
sensitive about contacting they start
calling the game over the top and this
time to Braun catches getting the
picture straight up here at Staples
likely witnesses to history tonight
LeBron James his 13 points away from
passing Michael Jordan on the all-time
scoring list and missed the playoffs and
that hasn't happened for LeBron James
his 2005
there's Caruso from outside second-year
player out of Texas A&M
[Applause]
James gets inside and a nice finish
their first second field goal that
defense by James on the help that's the
type of every possession
defense has bottle gets a lay back for
Haywood lines up open three Brown trying
to keep it alive Rondo with his third
rebound Williams gets inside Williams
flips it up and in fast break by the
Lakers oh man what is wrong with you
tonight you can't say no it's not that
what you said it's the way you said it
Rondo record that's this time last year
their 11th that the West is he start the
night watch the travail the once again
first possession to the Lakers it's
happened on for this year results in a
downtown market at great outside shooter
himself that one no outlet goes to Kuzma
he goes across and scores tile twos but
ties it at 81 on the pants and in the
finish by coos Caruso
there goes down set take that Mikael
about as the beginning 16 to 7
disparities threes last night in Toronto
Jess Tamaki with authority rest of us
going to the offensive glass as we get
another look at Rondo dishing to Java
[Music]
nice little slip touch screen near by
ready for a career as I keep that hot
hand underneath who's looked at shoot
score let it play a nice look by Royal
they're tied at 58 nice controlled by
couch I depicted to 13th time he's been
tied nobody's led by
- slam dunk it with one hand nice
recognition by Rondo wily veteran he
knows it Rajon he's got a jumper if he
wants us to Gloucester cornea then a
dive by Caruso and the assist to Rondo
on the backhand layout in that corner do
you get him an open shot you'll not get
down for me and I'll tell you what you
haven't watch this first entry he's
gonna see a great catch off the bond for
Rondo for the finish
well I mean it goes back to personnel to
a lot I think a lot of people wanted to
duplicate center that's successful what
to do pass up tops in the bronze game
and what had been a disappointing season
just to get as many opportunities that
wins as he can gonna help them off the
bond from Rondo you know what I mean you
got this young man in the NBA
[Applause]
Ben Williams in zaga voice of the NCAA
tournament Rondo who shows that ball
real early on those kind of dives that
time gets away with it as Gomes picks on
three out of four and just like that the
Lakers are down one possession 27:24
John with 13 to shoot 40 I've a high
dribble Lance
can score
any strumming it as he goes down to the
other point lead biggest we've seen
Marvin Williams can't connect Rhonda
straight past
[Applause]
have some fun up there right now Raja
Drive tick on its way down it goes
Reggie Bullock from rajon rondo it's a
13-2 for run said that against the
Clippers just recently here comes Jay
Jay leaves it now back for all goes back
to Jay Jay although a story on the board
Jumeirah John Romo pelicans scoring
column picks up the steel gives it to
Rondo and he knows how he's gonna get it
back that shot anytime he wants a love
to see him get back to down on the block
we were watching Paul George numbers he
was just fantastic the entire season
over McGee back get him rebound
Rondo quick release begin with the other
[Applause]
[Music]
first-round pick larger in last year's
draft
again
but I'm thinking Jane Chu spent 60 years
in the mid 66
the National Basketball Association
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content